[Music]
on this friday night fighting the fourth
wave
grim signs of what canada could be
facing this fall as alberta reverses
course bringing back public health
measures and paying people to get
vaccinated we have left no stone
unturned and yet we have the lowest
vaccination rate in canada
[Music]
facing a tough fight the liberals
sharpen their campaign strategy while
the ndp pushes to boost seats in quebec
with a province specific platform
president biden gets an up-close look at
the catastrophic damage from hurricane
ida with waters receding the urgent
calls for funding to help me better
prepared and the spectacular swims that
landed a canadian paralympian in the
record books twice in one day
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
it is not a position anyone hoped we'd
be in but as we head into the labor day
long weekend new federal modeling shows
a resurgence of covid19 in canada and
unless more people get vaccinated fast
infection rates could rise higher than
they've ever been the delta driven
fourth wave has case numbers rising
rapidly vaccines do work and have slowed
hospitalizations and deaths it is the
unvaccinated who are now filling up
hospital beds in the last week there
were an average of 1200 coveted patients
in hospital more than 440 of them in icu
right now about 3 400 people are testing
positive every day and if we continue on
the same path canada could see up to 15
000 cases per day by the end of
september that would overwhelm our
hospitals
if you want to avoid uh uh what we
experienced in the second or third wave
especially with all of us you know going
back inside you know with the fall in
school and the colder weather let's get
our vaccination rates up you know we we
have that window of opportunity it's
never too late but uh let's get going
one province in particular is driving up
the numbers alberta has the lowest
vaccination rates and the most active
cases in the country nearly 13 000
people there have active covet
infections right now today premier jason
kenney who has laid low for weeks
emerged along with alberta's chief
medical officer of health kenny reversed
course reinstating a province-wide mass
mandate starting tomorrow mass will be
mandatory in indoor public spaces though
not in schools and the government is
going to pay people to get vaccinated
if you just haven't gotten around to it
for the love of god please get
vaccinated now
and if you do we will now pay you a
hundred dollars
more on alberta in just a moment but
first the big picture about kobit 19 in
canada jamie morocco has our top story
tonight
canada's public health agency says the
window to avoid a troubling trajectory
of covid cases come fall is closing the
moment you get people back indoors
to to access all those important
essential
things that we need to do
we will see
accelerations putting school businesses
and our social lives on the line again
no one wants to go back into as you say
lockdown but strong restrictions are not
off the table and the solution is the
same one it's been for months would you
like a covet vaccine today more vaccines
that's why you know people are saying we
need vaccine mandates you know so that
we can keep university schools
places of employment open the
announcement of vaccine passport
programs in bc ontario and quebec have
helped boost covet vaccination bookings
but some provinces have plateaued 77
percent of the eligible population is
fully vaccinated but as dr teresa tam
pointed out at 63 percent 18 to 39 year
olds are lagging behind we're looking at
certainly over 80 percent coverage
in that eligible population as fast as
possible setting up perhaps unrealistic
deadline of labor day monday it's a
pandemic of the industry indoctrinated
people that don't believe in covet or
afraid of the vaccine and they're not
getting vaccinated those are the people
that are going to end up you know
getting coveted new cases among
unvaccinated people are now 12 times
higher than among the fully vaccinated a
number experts say we can still control
but it's now or never jamie rocker
global news toronto
in alberta icu's are now 95 percent full
and scheduled surgeries are being
postponed the new restrictions announced
there today include that indoor mask
mandate and a ban on alcohol sales after
10 pm in bars and restaurants and
unvaccinated albertans are strongly
urged to limit indoor social gatherings
i know that this is disappointing to
some who have started to move back into
their office
some that have planned large social
events
these steps
are the least intrusive things we think
are needed and they're temporary
100 gift cards will be given to people
who get vaccinated premier kenny was
asked what kind of message that sends
why the province is rewarding people who
have been holding out while putting
others at risk here's how he responded
i wish we didn't have to do this
but this is not a time for moral
judgments this is a time to get people
vaccinated we have done everything we
can left no stone unturned made it as
easy as possible we have left no stone
unturned and yet we have the lowest
vaccination rate in canada
critics say much more could have been
done and that it was a mistake to lift
all public health restrictions july 1st
and that vaccine passports would
incentivize people to get their shots
kenny is resisting them earlier this
week ontario's premier doug ford who
also opposed vaccine passports reversed
his position the day they were
implemented there the number of
vaccination bookings in ontario more
than doubled
vaccine passports are also in place in
manitoba now as it grapples with a
fourth wave manitobans are now required
to show a vaccine card or qr code
proving they're fully vaccinated before
accessing many public spaces including
restaurants gyms movie theaters and
concerts next tuesday the province will
also reduce large outdoor gathering
limits from fifteen hundred people to
five hundred
on the campaign trail today liberal
leader justin trudeau used the topic of
vaccine passports to attack his
conservative rival david aiken is
traveling with the liberals and joins me
now david
well donna with the liberals now
trailing the tories in several polls
liberal leader justin trudeau is now
sharpening his attack on his chief
opponent aaron o'toole and trudeau's
main line of attack friday was to
contrast the liberal vaccine mandate
policy
we'll ensure that everyone
12 or older on a plane or train
is fully vaccinated with the policy of
o'toole and the conservatives now aaron
o'toole has said he would rip up this
commitment on vaccines
i think canadians know that's precisely
the wrong choice at the wrong time
trudeau took on o'toole on that score in
the first french language leaders debate
thursday night
liberals were pleased with their leaders
strong performance but blac quebecois
leader e francois blanchet also had a
strong night and unless the liberals can
steal some of those bq seats there
really is no path to the majority that
the liberals were hoping for when they
called this snap election donna
okay david thanks the party leaders were
tested in a two-hour french language
debate in quebec last night a province
with some highly contested races mike
lacature is traveling with the
conservatives
well donna aaron o'toole's performance
in last night's french debate wasn't
spectacular but it also wasn't a repeat
of 2019
when then conservative leader andrew
scheer fell on his face in this case
avoiding defeat might be a victory in
itself
avoiding major missteps and playing it
safe may sum up the conservative
campaign so far often sticking to his
insulated studio setup in ottawa the
conservative leader has held few rallies
across the country most have been inside
reception halls
safely away from potential protesters
even while announcing his plan to tackle
gang violence o'toole appeared friday in
a hotel instead of the streets of
montreal where there has been a sharp
rise in the number of gun crimes this
year
one issue that continues to dog o'toole
is his lack of clarity on what he'll do
with the day care deals the trudeau
government inked with a number of
provinces before the election notably
quebec he has been asked point blank
will he tear up those contracts with the
provinces if he's elected prime minister
o'toole continues to be non-committal we
will deliver for all families support
to make sure they have access to child
care wherever they are and more support
for families in the lower incomes we
will also build collaborative relations
with the premiers not answering that
question could be a problem for the
conservative leader as the party tries
to court votes of young families in the
final two weeks of this campaign
donna
all right mike thanks the ndp leader
spent another day in quebec offering a
platform specific to that province a
sign how intent the party is on trying
to win more seats in quebec abigail
beeman has a reality check on the ndp's
hopes in la belle provence
[Music]
personalized punjabi poutine truck in
montreal a debate and then day three a
platform drop in quebec city they want
to send a strong message
to nationalists in quebec that you know
they are not going to centralize
everything the platform reiterates much
of what's in the national plan this
isn't a plan to respond to
mr lego this is a plan to respond to
quebecers but it clearly answers quebec
premier francois lego's laundry list for
those who want to be prime minister
singh is offering more money for
immigration and an increase in health
transfers our first commitment is to
reverse the cuts brought in by harper
that have been maintained by justin
trudeau the strategy to go directly to
quebec to quebecers i think will pay off
because at the end of the line
i don't think anybody in the streets
talks about jurisdictions they want help
for their issues in 2019 the ndp lost
all but one seat in quebec a big
roadblock was bill 21 quebec's law
banning religious symbols it remains a
challenge of course singh repeatedly
dodges the question of how much bill 21
and racism dogs him two years later i
don't want to make anything about myself
stressing voters now know him better and
like what they see we need to work extra
hard to convince those that are willing
to consider voting for for for a man
who's wearing a religious symbol the
party talks about picking up between
four and ten seats here experts say
that's optimistic but they also point to
current positive momentum and even
picking up a couple of seats would be
seen as a win doubling or tripling the
party's current standing in the province
abigail beeman global news quebec city
the royal canadian navy has ruled out
disciplinary action for senior officers
who joked about sex during an official
zoom call the defense minister harjit
sajan ordered a review of the incident
in march after global news reported that
the military had ended its internal
investigation without speaking to all of
those involved in a statement the navy
did say that the allegations
demonstrated the sexualized culture that
the royal canadian navy must continue to
confront and that the trust must be
re-established in those affected
the american president gets a first-hand
look coming up his promise to help
hurricane ravaged louisiana
the cleanup is continuing across much of
the northeastern united states after the
record flash flooding there at least 45
people are known to have died in the
disaster that affected five states the
process of assessing the damage is only
just beginning jackson proskow is in
philadelphia jackson
donna the receding floodwaters have
revealed billions of dollars in damage
and the need to spend billions of
dollars in the future to harden cities
and towns against storms like ida which
are only expected to become more
frequent and severe
this is just the beginning of a cleanup
that will take months we lost so much
stuff majority of this is going to go in
the garbage in the places hit hardest by
ida the floodwaters came so fast they
damaged or destroyed almost everything
they touched it was so much water it was
so forceful that it kicked the door open
went into the lone dock area
kicked the wall out
the record-setting rainfall had nowhere
to go inundating subways and freeways
and homes where people drowned unable to
escape including a two-year-old boy in
new york that's the scariest thing i've
ever like thought of
is to have have water flood a room and
then you not be able to open the door
that gets out
in louisiana where entire towns were
wiped off the map officials warn it
could take a month or more for power to
be restored
president joe biden toured the damage
friday and promised to help rebuild and
recover it seems to me we can save a
whole lot of money
and a whole lot of pain
pain for our constituents if we build
back we build it back in
a better way
ida was a storm for the history books
but certainly not the last chapter
offering a preview of a future full of
catastrophic weather events things that
we were told are once in a century
are now happening regularly
but bluntly they're also getting worse
oh my god in the last five years
hurricanes have caused an estimated 400
billion dollars in damage in the united
states the true toll of ida both in
dollars and in lives may not be known
for weeks
jackson proskow global news philadelphia
swimming and sprinting to the podium
still ahead canada's latest paralympic
medals
that's canadian danielle doris after
taking the gold the 18 year old from new
brunswick won the women's s7 50 meter
butterfly event and she broke the world
record twice in one day first in the
qualifying heats and again with her gold
medal finish
and on land sprinter marissa papa
constantino raced to her first medal for
team canada the 21 year old from toronto
won bronze in the women's t-64 100 meter
final she set a new personal best of
13.07 seconds canada now has 20 medals
at the tokyo paralympics
and here's some news you can use or at
least dance to abba is making a comeback
nearly 40 years after breaking up the
swedish pop group is releasing a new
album voyage it's called it has 10 songs
and drops november 5th but the first two
singles are out now here's one of them
i still have faith in you
[Music]
okay well not really danceable but i'm
sure the other ones will be the music
video gives fans a sneak peek at the
abba avatars that will take to the stage
for a digital concert series wild global
national will be back in a moment
[Music]
disruption is
creative rihanna taylor ahmad aubry
disruption is destructive
[Music]
disruption is opportunity
people here in the square who have a
whole new hope and they're so eager now
and it's exhausting the thing you want
to do as a reporter and as a journalist
is to bear witness so i guess you could
say journalists are sort of drawn to
disruption
well that's a clip from a documentary
airing next week disruption 20 years of
global national yes it has been 20 years
since this news broadcast first went on
the air 20 years today in fact i wasn't
in the anchor chair back then i was a
foreign correspondent for nbc news based
in london it was this guy who launched
global national all those years ago
kevin newman is with us from his cottage
in ontario tonight kevin how are you
i'm in a log cabin in the middle of the
woods so i'm really great actually
[Laughter]
sounds ideal hey kevin take us back to
2001. you went on the air with a brand
new newscast not knowing that eight days
later the biggest terror attack on
american soil would take place
how big a challenge was that
well don it was a huge challenge i mean
we've barely been together for a week uh
when 9 11 happened and they're all kinds
of challenges of trying to get across
the border that day with a brand new
team and a brand new newscast
but we rose to the occasion i think it
was a terrible few days those of us old
enough to remember and
it was stunning i mean those those twin
towers that collapsed had most of the
transmission towers on it
and so when those towers went down our
ability to report what was happening in
manhattan was also
severely hampered as well i had just
moved from new york city to start
anchoring global national
and uh it was personal to me i knew
people in the towers uh the the city i
had been my home for the last 10 years
and so it was a it was a very difficult
day but what it did do to a young
newscast
was it forged us and it i think it made
us uh better than we would have been
because we were so tested and and it was
it was it was it was a day that i think
all of us who went through it we'll
never forget
yeah it changed well it changed the
world it's uh not an overstatement uh
kevin we both reported from afghanistan
i know
you know uh that western journalists
can't function there without translators
and fixers you've been working hard to
get afghans out of the country what has
that been like
oh it's been frustrating as you know don
i mean these these relationships that
are forged in in disaster zones or in
conflict zones are are really tight and
what translators and fixers do for
journalists for soldiers for aid workers
is they are the conduit to the culture
that we visit the languages and they
help keep us safe
and you know the war in afghanistan was
very much a part of what happened after
9 11 and ended up it turns out being
that 20-year arc
some uh afghan interpreters were able to
get out i've been working uh
volunteering with a group of soldiers to
try to get to the rest of them out but
as you and and the viewers well know
that's not an easy task now
the whole story is absolutely
heartbreaking and has caused sleepless
nights for so many people kevin i want
to
talk to you about some advice you gave
me when i took over this job from you
you said the relationship that matters
the most is the one that we have
with our viewers
and i really took that to heart because
it's so true
well i mean even as we're talking now
we're thinking about the impact our
words the choices that have been made by
your team and previous to that my team
uh
made
it it it is a very intimate and
important relationship and and more
important than that i mean the
credibility of the words that we speak
and
and and and the stories that we choose
um matter and um
respecting the viewer i think donna as
you as you always have and you know i've
watched the last 10 years and you've
you've kept that very much alive and and
center that that is the highest
responsibility i think that any
journalist has is understanding um that
that we are there to serve
and we are there to protect in some ways
and we're there to verify
truth that's sure what we try to do and
and uh it's a privilege doing this job i
know you felt that too kevin and
what uh i want to say the way i want to
wrap up is really we wouldn't be doing
this if it wasn't for our loyal viewers
so thanks to all of you thanks thanks to
you kevin uh
uh catch some fish out there
and i want to say it was really fun
collaborating with you on on the
on the documentary as well it was you
were one of the very few people in
journalism that i hadn't worked with and
it was a pleasure it was a pleasure
thanks kevin
and you can watch disruption 20 years of
global national on september 10th right
here on global or online at
globalnews.ca
global national
and that is global national for this
friday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada was taken near grand bank
newfoundland and labrador
thanks for watching robin gill will be
at the anchor desk this weekend and i'll
see you next thursday from bedeck nova
scotia ahead of the federal election
thanks for watching bye
[Music]